by Fall the time has come for families
across the far south to leave their
summer
homes but some are far from ready to say
goodbye after almost a year
apart time together is
precious
like us it can take years for Albatross
to find their
soulmate and longdistance romances take
work but it's all been worth
it
at 75
days wandering Albatross have one of the
longest incubations of any
[Music]
bird until their egg
hatches they'll have to feed in
ships
but our oceans are more dangerous than
ever
[Music]
before every
goodbye could be his
last
and he's
[Music]
gone each year he's having to fly
further and further to find enough
food testing their relationship to the
[Music]
Limit failure to provide is now ending
more and
more of these Epic
love
[Music]
stories